Ethan: 3
Ethan: 2
Ethan:  1
Ethan: That was really good. Amy: That was good.
Ethan singing: doo doo doo doo
Ethan: I'm rolling and polling around!
Pam: Shoe cam.
Ethan: You ready? Mark: Yup.
Pam: Butt cam!
Ethan: 3, 2...
Ethan: Good
Mark: Alright
Amy: Nice ass  Tyler: Lotta ass
Pam: ASS ASS ASS ASS ASS ASS ASS
Pam: Did you see...did you see butt cam?
Mick: I did
Mick: I don't know if you noticed, there's a...
Mick: there's a little...pebble of...
Mick: wetness, on Mark`s butt.
*Pam laughing* Mick: Right between his cheeks.
Kathryn: Hello!
Pam: Hi you're my favorite! *Kathryn giggles*
Amy: Oh, ok. That's fine
Pam: She's my favorite Kathryn
Amy: You didn't say that *Pam laughs*
Ethan- Is it in night vision mode? Woah!
Pam: No it's not, infrared is off.
Amy: *whispering* Don't look
Amy: Don't look at me
Pam: You're laying with another man!
Amy: We were holding hands earlier. Pam: I'm gonna tell Mark
Pam: Awww that's so romantic
Amy: It's very cold
Pam: Awww, keeping you warm
Amy: We're just cuddling
Mark: Achoo, oh no I'm not really dead.
Mark: Uh oh,
Mark: My plan has been foiled. Here is a secret,
Mark:I'm trying to ruin the colonel's life who is actually Warfstache.
Mark: And I'm gonna steal a body,
Mark: because he ran off with my wife and
Mark: it's all his fault and definitely not her choice
Mark: So yeah, she must've gone crazy or something to leave me, so uh, but things don't go right.
Mark: And then I do die, but I've died lots of times and I've come back lots of times, it's great
Mark: Beat death and that sort of thing
Mark: So then in the end I take over the mayor's body, but that's not Darkiplier. Darkiplier is the mayor's
Mark: spirit in my body. My broken bloody body. He wants to go back and he wants revenge. And that's the whole crux of the story
Mark: Make sense? Yeah, cool, okay.
Mark: Alright, we ready? This is going to be -- oh man that is close to my face.
Ethan: Alright ready? Tyler: Yeah.
Ethan: Oh! I have a wedgie in my butt! Okay!
Mick: Oh, shit
Mick: Well, fuck
Mark: Fuck!
*Everyone except Mick start laughing*
Mark: You're off the hook
Mick: Can we- can we go up from that, or is that impossible? Fuck let's just do it again. Shit.
Mark: It's fine, you got it, you're a hero!
Mick: Alright! Hand me that fingerprinting kit behind you, partner.
Mark: Maybe, maybe just a little bit of emotive from the camera movement
Mark: You know how like because uh, this is a person so if-if he says something shocking
Mark: you know kind of like reel back like a- just a- just a barely little bit, something to give it a little nuance
Pam: *singing* laying down and giving direction Markiplier!
Mark: I'm a man of many talents.
*Everyone chuckles*
Pam: Did you drool a little bit on the floor?
Mark: I sure did.
Pam: *In Kiddie Voice* Oh my gosh it's Amy!
Pam: Amy what are you doing?
Amy: I'm boartin' a thing
Pam: You're boartin' a thing?
Pam: Does that mean writing? Amy: Yeah boartin'
Pam: Ohh slates! *gasps* Slates! Oh, wow!
Amy: Our chalk sucks. We forgot to buy new chalk.
Pam: Oh look at this, a super official set list.
Amy: We made a set list this morning.
Look at this bad boy, all the shots
Pam: Oh my gosh!
Pam: That`s so good
Pam: Done?
Amy: We're so prepped.
Pam: Is it done?
Amy: It's not done, nothing is done.
Amy: Nothing is done...
Pam:  *Singing* Kathryn having a sit, Kathryn,
Pam: Sittin' and singin'!
Pam: You-- ruined my Kathryn sitting shot!
Pam: Okay, back to Kathryn sitting. *continues singing* Yeah Kathryn
sitting on a couch
Kathryn she's in charge of sound
~da~da~da~da~da~
She can hear us all
better than we can hear herrrr, hu-
What the-
What the?
There's Kathrynnnn *giggle* yeah!
Amy: first scene, take four  *Slate claps*
Mark: All you guys doing the voices and lines and acting stuff you guys were really solid in that last one so I think-
Ethan: I'm fffucking horrible..
Mark: It was all Ethan and the gimbal. Blame the gimbal. Is my cravat where it was? My cravat seems to have fallen apart.
Ethan: Dude, your cravat is HOT.
Mark: Amy, I need cravat support!
Kathryn: Amy help.
Amy: Cravat? -uh- Check!
Mark: It's all kinds of funky.
Pam: You're doin' so good.
Amy: Yeah it is. 'Kay, but it's just under. Oh, it's so--Oh, I touched the drool pool!
*Kathryn laughing*
Pam: EEEEEWWWWW!!!
Mark: Is that okay, right there?
Amy: Yeah, it looks good.
Mark: Okay, cool. Alright, here we go!
Amy: You can have it, there you go
Pam: Ew, gross
Mark: Everyone's happy
*tape ripping*
*Tyler humming as he dances with Dummy Jim*
Mark: Is this really a spotlight though? Taping up my crotch. Is this the highlight of you guys' career?
Pam: Yeah it is!
Ethan: Absolutely, mine dude.
Amy: Put it on my resume!
Ethan: I was such a big Markiplite
Amy: Here we go we're gonna get-
Tyler: Intimate.
Amy: Mm, Yeah...
Ethan: HOT.
Ethan: Just whoo
Amy: We'll add like a flurg...We'll add a dick if you want.
*Mark Giggles*
Mark: I'm so glad we're all this close. *everyone giggles* Now... We weren't before.
Amy: We're about to get closer.
Pam: This is an observational sport
And Ethan's coming in on the right making sure that he gets that hand just right
And Amy's already working towards the face, sending a focus on the nose
rounding out to radiate at the top of the head working on that crown
Ethan is now rounding out the left hand. It's looking great ladies and gentlemen!
I think he may be a contender for first place on floor stamping.
Mark: Do I win an award for this?
Pam: Yeah?
Mark: Or am I like one of those nude models at an art, like, art class?
Kathryn: He has a stub hand!
Ethan: He do.
Mark *singing* Stub hand!
Amy: What? I don't know what's... --Kathryn *singing* Stub Hand!
Pam: Yay!
Amy: Okay, big reveal time!
*Mark groaning "Ohh my f-"*
Ethan: Stub hand!
*Mark grunts while standing up*
Mark: That looks great, actually!
Amy: Fascinating.
Ethan: Oh, Now we just gotta do the crotch. Just huuuuh.
I really want to give you a good bellend
Kathryn: Admiring his work
Amy: We are going to cover our beautiful work.
Ethan: Aaaahhhh
*Foot steps*
Pam: What is that?
Ethan: The 360 camera was in the bathroom.
Pam *gasps*
Nooo! What?
Ethan: Someone was trying to get my nudes! *stomps off*
Pam: OoooooOOooOOooOhhhHHH!!!
Amy: Hello!
Amy: Ordering fooood!
Pam: Oooooooooh Amy! -- Amy: That's me!
Mark: So, after uh, an afternoon of problems, that oddly enough, like, I thought that took many more hours than it actually did,
But uh, we're well on our way. We've got technical problems out of the way, and we're gonna get our second scene done.
Third, technically.
Amy: Woot!
Pam Yeah!
*Kathryn neck crack*
Pam: Oh god...
Kathryn: Rocks. *pointing to her calves*
Tyler, [offscreen] I mean it's- it's...You could have gone upstairs to find him, and then...
Ethan, [offscreen]: One more time
Pam: Oh Dayum! Oh Dayum! Thats-
Kathryn: I got calves.
Pam: Oh my gosh!
Kathryn: I got calves!
Pam: That's crazy!
Ethan: Calves at the ready.
Pam: She's got calves f-- Calf-ryn-
Pam: Calf-ryn!
Kathryn: I've got calves for days!
Pam: Calf-ryn!!
Kathryn: Calf-ryn! ahaha!
Ethan: I get it! Oh ho ho! *rubs nips*
Mick: I love that you went to cover your mouth-
And then as you sneezed you just removed your arm
Tyler: Your arm went like-- Well, like-
You were like, Achoo!!! *Demonstrates sneeze*
Mick, in background: Good job partner.
Pam: look at the doo-doodles.
Amy: Doodles! I be doodlin'
Pam: Look at the- *giggles*
Pam: *singing* She was born for this!
Amy: Murder scene two, take two! *Slate claps*
Mark: Kay
Pam: Dat was great, dat was great
Ethan:You ready?
Mark(Damien): This-This isn't right!
Tyler(Butler): *interrupts mid-"this"* Right-
*shakes head*
*Shoos Tyler away*
*Stomps on dummy*
Mark, off screen: Has Larry texted you? I haven't seen--
Pam: Sorta looks like a man isn't studying his lines...let's see your badge... lets see your credentials
Let's see your credentials...
Mick: Ahhh!
Pam: *laugh* Perfect! Yes.
Okay Kathryn, I need to see your credentials
Kathryn: Ummm...ummm.
Pam: Officer! Arrest this lady!
Mick: Eugh! *Pretends to throw badge*
Pam: There's our leader
Hard at work... S-studying... lines
Mark: I'm ready to go.
Pam: Studying lines...
Mark: All my lines are up in here. I wrote the damn thing.
Pam: ...Well it looks like you're doing a great job!
Mark: Thanks
Mark: gggggg boy! No! Ahhhhh
Pam: Any-any, any words of wisdom you wanna give to your audience right now?
Mark: We've got four scenes done of 60 aand wee haaave two dicks. *Pam giggle*
Tyler: Wait we have four done?
[Mark, off screen] four of 60, yes.
*unknown humming*
Pam: Dun~duh~dun~nuh Dun~duh~un~nuh
Ethan: *Hums, whispers* I love a good zoom.
*"hhh" after panning to either the tray or Tyler's face four times*
Ethan: Do~do~do~do~do~do~do
*Light banging from Pam*
*Flem noises via Pam*
*Just some bouncy music*
Mark: Nooooooo
Ethan: I didn't know sorry
Mark: Nooooo *groaning*
Ethan: *singing* Rearrange my asshole~ *five more times*
Rearrange my-
Amy: Ethan!
Ethan: What?
Kathryn: Stop singing about your asshole!
Ethan: Ah, its a good-
Pam: Ponyo! Ponyo!
Amy: Ponyo-
Ethan: Ponyo Ponyo!!
Mick: Stop!
*Cute Ethan laugh*
*Many "Ponyo"s in the distance*
Mick: STOP!
*More Ethan laughter*
*Almost awkwardly long solo laughter from Mark*
Mark: Dead...
*odd sound to mimic throat vocalization of it being sliced? followed by laughter*
Mark: Ahhhhh...
Tyler: I didn't know when to go.
*Mark's crazed laughter, followed by a hum*
Tyler: *draws Mark's attention with a deep voice* Yummy~
Pam: *quiet voice* Are we good?
Mark: *Flatly* No.
Chris: No, no, no, but thats what you told me, like thats what I'm saying.
Mick: Yeah, yeah like I- and that always weirded me out 'cause I was like how are they updating the actual-
...hardware.
*pam giggling*
With, uh- Hi, how you doing?
*uhhuh huh*
Dan(?): A little BTS actions, eh?
Chris: No, no, I'm in SAG, I'm sorry.
Pam: Oh
Chris: S- You need permission
Pam: Do I really?
Chris: Well you can look at me, actually, but first of all ladies and gentlemen do you know who I am?
Then go away, take a drink, and calm down.
Thank you very much.
Pam: So sor- So sorry, Sir.
Ethan: We're gonna to go on a night time excursion adventure.
Pam: Kay.
Ethan: *Bad Australian accent* Alright here we go.
Mike: Just. Please be careful there are so many spiders out there.
Like... huge..
Like just face eating spiders
Okay?
*Pam laughing*
Ethan: Okay let's go.
Pam: Okay okay
Okay
Okay, I gotta walk
Ethan: Ohh, it actually works
Pam: I gotta walk with... my hands in the air
Ethan: Dude this is like Outlast. I hate it. *little laugh*
*Pam laughter*
Okay, so word on the street is this place is haunted...
...by farts (giggling)
Come here
At this gazebo there used to be a bathroom. In this bathroom, they say...
the dump happened.
*whispering* It was a stinky one
Marvel in it's glory. Also, too. There's like.. you can see- can you see the spiders?
Can you see the spiders? That's a scary guy. OoOoOOo
Ethan: spooky
Ethan: You should put shoes on
Pam: I'll put my Flippy floppies on, Oh they're all the way upstairs...
Ethan: I'll go with you!!
Pam: Okay!
Ethan: Let's go on an adventure!
We're gonna go on an adventure!
*EEEEEE*
Pam: Look in here!!
*Gasps* Mark: Ghosts?
Ethan: Oh no,  towels!
*Laughter ensues*
Pam: You guys gotta come with us.
Amy: Where you going?
Ethan: Go down to like, the path.
Kathryn: Noo.
Amy: No, there's snakes down there.
Kathryn: Yeah.
Pam: At night time?
Amy: They said there were snakes, and they're mating.
He was like there's a black snake and a pink snake, and they're mating so be careful of the snakes
Pam: Well We're not going all the way down. We're just going to like-
Ethan:We're gonna go to the Harry Potter place
Amy: That's where they were!
Pam: What? *Everyone giggles*
Amy: No!
Pam: Snakes have sex in the Harry Potter place?
Kathryn: Yeah.
Amy: Apparently.
Pam: It makes sense.
Kathryn:We should go to the wine cellar it's safer.
Amy: *Gasp* We could go to the wine cellar.
Pam: I feel like we're asking for something bad.
Ethan: Me too.
Amy: Can you see anything, Ethan, even remotely?
Ethan: Yes I can see everything
Pam: If there are spirits in this wine cellar-
Ethan: Noo! No, don't do that!
Kathryn:I don't like it!
Amy: Lets bring the Ouiji board down here!
Kathryn&Ethan: Noo!
Pam:It's- You guys!
Amy: Out stretch your hand
Pam:It's right here. I'm not afraid.
Come on! Come on, Ethan.
Ethan: No. Dude, I have a video camera.
Amy: I was so scared.
Pam: Come on. Come here. Come here!
Ethan: Dude I am afraid.
Amy: Come on.
Pam: *Flatly* Come on.
Ethan: I can't.
Amy: You can.
Amy: Ethan..
Pam&Amy: Ethan join us.
Ethan: No, I hate this so much.
Pam: Come down stairs.
Ethan: I hate this so much.
Ethan: I literally hate this so much.
Amy: Ohhh I stepped on something crunchy...
*Pam laughter*
Amy: Okay, I don't like it. I'm donezo.
Amy: You don't like it.
Kathryn: What?
*Amy&Pam giggling*
Ethan: Wow I hate that.
Amy: Give me g- oh...
Ethan: Here, we're gonna do a bit alright.
Hello. Its me, Ethan. going on a ghost adventure...
*Piano plays in the distance*
Lets go...
On the housey house
Oh...
*long pause for the piano*
Don't like that
*Piano keys smash*
Ethan: oH MY GOD. if you only knew-
*they all laugh, Ethan wheezes*
Amy: What? *Mark 'Hmm's* What?
Mark: What?
Amy: What?
Amy:You wanna see something spooky?
Mark: Always
Amy: My prop room
*Mark Mhms*
Amy: Wait
Mark: I'm waiting
Amy: Wait...
Mark: Okay...
Mark: Waiting.
Amy: It's not gonna do it.
There it goes.
Amy: You see that.
Mark: No.
Amy: See it's flickerin'.
Amy: It's gonna start blinkin'.
Mark: Okay.
Amy: It's real spooky.
Mark: It's Spooky.
Amy: You saw it yesterday though right?
Mark: Yeah, well, it's not a camera so...
Amy: *Groan*
Amy: Has that water damage always been there?
*Mark high pitched MMM, Tyler laughing*
Amy: I don't recognize that.
Mark: ...mmmaybe
Amy: It's not doing it!
Mark: Huuh!!
Tyler: Jeeze. *laughter*
Amy: Can someone vouch for me?
Tyler: For what?
Amy: That this room was spooky yesterday.
Tyler: I've never found that room spooky though
Amy: Damn it! The light was flickering like crazy.
Tyler: Really?
Amy: Yeah.
Tyler: Hmm. *shrug* -- Mark laughter*
Ethan: *bap bap bap* Hey, do you--
Kathryn: They're trapped in there, get them out!!
Ethan: Hey, what do you-- *More baps*
Hey, blink! *giggling between the two*
*Big sigh* Well let me tell you a thing or two about a thing or two - we've been filming once, twice, three times, four times for the past
Four, five, to six days a week
Kathryn: Fourteen hours.
Ethan: 14 hours, 12 years, let me tell you-
Pam: You know whats really funny is that now that i can't see your blue hair not only do you
sound like Dana Carvey, but you kind of look like him, too.
Pam: Then there's serious. There's really, really serious... serious.. s-
Planning and scheduling and then not so serious following
And *giggling* and then the skillful bottle tossing and then the serious- Whoa. What is.. even...
Are you just listening to it?
*Kathryn giggles*
Is he- Is he assaulting you right now?
See this is the time to get BTS because-
Ethan: what happens with the boom mic stays with the boon mic.
Pam: Boon mic? *giggles*
Ethan: Boon mic.
Pam: Oh goodness look at those little cheeks, I just wanna squish 'em. Look at those ones.
Ethan: Oh stop.
Kathryn: No- They're talking about you in the other room.
Ethan: What?
Mark: We got a little change.
Ethan: A change? No way *taps shoes*
Mark: So-
Pam: Okay so we're gonna go on a really quick tour of the premises.
*kind of fighting sounds but not really, in the background*
Kay so this is the front door aaand s- it opens.
Kathryn&Ethan:Everybody clap your hands! *clap x7*
Ethan: How low can you go?
Can you-  Fuck.
*breaks into laughter*
Pam: Can you give a fuck?
Anyways, so before my tour was so rudely interrupted...
Here's the ground outside. It's got knights ...
And then it's got... it's got butts, the knight butts.
And then we go this way and this is the area that we call the party area
this party area
we call it the party area because it's got..
crazy-cool party lights that go woooo! Yeah, party liights.
Oh, no murder scene! *sings* Party, body, body, party. Barty, pody, pody, barty...
That didn't make any sense.
We know what's in here. Oh my gosh. It's a garage and it has a Hummer in it?!
That's, ah, haha.
Okay- That's new. I did not notice that that was there.
And then back here
there's
There's a restroom
that has somebody's shirts that have been there for a couple days now, and then there's a theater~
There's- Is there a light to turn- turn on this theater?
Yeah
Here's the theater. This is where we watched the Game of Thrones the other night.
There is a bug on my glasses.
Can you see that? Can see the bug that just- yeah. Landed on my glasses while I was giving this tour.
Hey, uninvited!
See it's gone now. Huh. Anyway, so yeah, then there's a stage thing.
You- you could perform on?
See here. Lets see- Let's see if I can set this up.
It's like--
Ladies and Gentlemen. I'm about to perform a diddy!
For you!
Okay.
*Background*
Robert(Chef): And stay outta my kitchen!
Tyler(Butler): Now, now.
*Mick smells vigorously*
*Followed by Pam giggles*
*Tyler hopping/clapping sounds*
Pam: Butt Caaaaaam. Booty.
Pam: Get it, Ethan, you're doing a great job. You're doin a great-
Ethan: PaAam!
*Background* Mark(Damien): I know it will take some getting used to. But there is no one else I'd rather have along side me to fight and defend this great city of ours.
Mick: *Whispers* Stop.
*Background* Mark: Now, I'll see you at the poker table soon.
Pam: Are you trying to give me a taste of my own medicine?
Mick: You like it? Do you like it?
Pam: I was made for this.
Mick: You like it?
Pam: Yes. Yes. *giggles*
Mick: Oh god, you do, look at this. You are immune.
Pam: Give me mooore~ *both laughing*
Pam: Roberrrrt.
Robert: Mhm.
Pam: Ohhh I caught you eating.
It's really hard to be sassy when you've got a food full mouth full- food full mouth full? Mouth full food full. *giggling*
Robert: Food full of mouth full.
Pam: Wait. What's your- what's your weapon of choice? Wheat Thins?
Robert: Wheat Thins, for now.
Beggars can't be choosers.
Pam: Yeah. Well. I mean if you had to choose. What would be your snack?
Robert: Potato chips.
Pam: Just regular-?
Robert: Just, no. I need some- I need those uh...
Hawaiian sweet and spicy deals.
Pam: Oooh yeah, that's good.
Robert: Yeah, those are good.
Pam: Thats good.
*Sound of slapping/punching/beating meat*
*Mark looking very distressed*
*More sound of slapping/punching/beating meat*
Tyler: Woah!
Ethan: That's the softest thing ever! Dude, holy shit.
*Laughter from everyone, but mostly Tyler.*
Ethan: Oh my god, That is so much softer than I thought it was going to be.
*wa-pap*
Ethan: Oh, that's going to be so easy.
Mark: Okay.
*Multiple Wham sounds from falling onto cushion*
Amy: Woah.
Mark: That was nice.
Amy: Good.
Ethan: *weird voice* I got blood hand! There's man blood- There's hand blood. There's-
Tyler: There's a really good angle right here.
Ethan: Theres a blood- There blood on my.. asshole.
Amy/Kathryn?: My ANUS is bleeding!
Ethan: My anus!
*Getting higher pitched* My anus is bleeding! My /ass/ is bleeding! It's bleeding!! For the love of god (Amy/Kathryn?: and all this is holy) hol- holy-
Mick: I'm glad you are taking this all seriously.
Ethan: My anus is bleeding!
Mark: I'm sorry!
Kathryn: It's not your fault!
Amy: No I'm a bad costume person for not bringing a tide pen-
Kathryn: I'm dark now!
Pam: Ohhh.
Amy: I see it.
Amy: Wanna see something spoopy?
Oh no it's not spooky!
*giggling*
Kathryn: That's horrifying! Look at that interior design choice.
*More giggling*
Kathryn: Whyyyy??
Amy: Okay, no, okay, here's the thing. Everytime I take the BTS  camera into this room it doesn't do it.
But I don't think that water damage was there when we got here.
Kathryn: What water damage? Oh- What are you talking about?
Amy: Did you see that before?
*Gasp*
Amy: - Damn it, Tyler! *Tyler laughs out of the room*
I thought it was doing it...
Kathryn: Nooooo...
Amy: Nooooo!
Kathryn: He was so young!!!
Amy: I'm going to the zoo.
Kathryn: He's coping a feel.
Amy: No! He's my son!
Kathryn: I don't know, I think the Jim's did something to him.
Amy: Oh I like my bounce. *Giggling*
Amy: Is it good?
Mick: Yes, take a look, they agree.
Kathryn: What's- what's your observation... of this?
Amy: Oh no, hold on.
Mick: It looks so fun, absolute insanity. What would- What's their name?
Kathryn: Leslie!
Amy: His! I thought he was a boy.
Mick: Leslie. Leslie is a very flexible, beautiful... woman.
Amy: She's seen better days.
*Mick giggles*
*Leslie caresses the statue butt*
Kathryn: Yeah, do you want to show them your crazy lady room?
Amy: Yes!
Kathryn: Ready? Dun DUN DUNNN
Amy: My prized posse-I'm going to be so sad when I'm going to have to take this room down.
Kathryn: You're gonna miss something and it's gonna be so well hidden that the next people miss it.
Amy: Well, yeah, because I have all these- I have so many sticky notes in there like in encyclopedias.
Kathryn: You wanna read some goodies for us?
Amy: Colonel colonel colonel colonel
Kathryn: Do you have a good- do you have a favorite sticky?
Amy: Uh, "What makes Gatorade that color and should we be putting in our bodies?"
I like this guy, it's really hard to see-
but I had to do this twice. I had to shred it properly. and then tape it.
Kathryn: I saw that, he kinda broke.
Amy: *Laugh* Whaat?
Kathryn: Amy, look- look at me real quick and think about that. *snort*
Amy: I don't want to talk about it.
I had a bad night.
I could leave a sticky note in one. Just murder.
*Kathryn giggling* Where should we put it? 873?
... It's gone forever now.
But now this doesn't say who did murder. It used to say "Who did murder?".
*Kathrine giggling up a storm*
Do you have a pen?
Mick: *mouthing words* What?
Pam: Busted! Ahhhh.
Mick: *eating sounds?*
Pam: He caught me!
Amy: WHAT? *both giggling*
Pam: Whats going on?
Ethan: WHAT?
Amy: *Off screen* WHAT?
JIM: Alright.
Ethan: Alright, I will not speak. If you get possessed, I'm fuckin' outta there.
JIM: Okay. Just get outta there and close the door.
JIM: I didn't- I didn't even know you were there, Mick.
Ethan: Don't even- Don't even pretend to be possessed because I will fucking be outtie.
JIM: But you have to do the ending.
Ethan: Nnnope! *laughing*
Ethan: Can I have someone's phone so I can use a flashlight if I need to get out?
JIM: *Snickering*
Kathryn: You want my phone, Ethan?
Ethan: A hundred percent. A. Hundred. Percent.
Kathryn: Here you go~
Ethan: Here we go...
Ethan: Uhhn!
JIM: -If you hurt Jim's tootsies. I got- Oh- Are you okay?
Ethan: I've been wounded! By the spirits!
Kathryn: Jim, no!
Ethan: AAAGHH!
Ethan: It hurts so bad.
*Pans to Tyler* The /Man/.
*talking in background*
Amy: It sounded hilarious.
Mick: It was great.
JIM: We good, Jim?
Ethan(JIM): Yeah, you wanna watch it, Jim?
JIM: Noo...
Ethan(JIM): Okay..
Ethan(Jim): Jim. Jim.
*Mark, Ethan, and Kathryn bust into a fit of laughter*